aujourd'hui dans la classe des 3e 2 du
collège la clé saint-pierre ses cours de
sciences avec le généthon
au programme court de génétique et
présentation du laboratoire et des
chercheurs de la fmt les ponts j'appris
bas des chaussures sur l'adn et sur les
cellules
ce les cellules souches ci est
bah du coup elle son métier aux
représentants que notre un travail et
sur l'adn et du coup bah enfin là
c'était un peu plus élaboré enfin ce qui
est logique et normal et du coup on a
appris plus parce qu'on n'était pas
allés aussi loin leurs professeurs du
jour jérôme denard ingénieur de
recherche qui explique ses missions ses
expérimentations et son programme de
recherche sur les patients atteint
d'amyotrophie spinale une maladie
neuromusculaire
ça a été très interactifs ils ont posé
beaucoup de questions des questions
pertinentes les questions auxquelles
j'avais même pas pensé
donc il y avait certains élèves qui qui
avait bien compris le mécanisme de
de thérapie génique dans cette es très
être très intéressant dans le cursus
d'un élève de 3e en sciences et vie de
la terre
on retrouve les gènes les chromosomes
ainsi que les cellules reproductrices
imparfait parallèle avec le travail des
chercheurs du généthon tous les ans on a
le téléthon qui qui intervient au mois
de décembre donc déjà ils sauront de
quoi ça parle
ils sont peut-être plus investi dans
dans le projet qui il aurait présenté
tous les ans la télévision mais pour eux
c'est un peu en dehors de ce qu'on en
fait au collège
donc là du coup ils ont un lien entre ce
que l'on fait au collège ce que font les
chercheurs et puis ce qui se passe à la
télévision
l'opération 1000 chercheurs dans les
collèges se terminera fin novembre après
avoir fait le tour des écoles pour
sensibiliser aux métiers de la science
et les enjeux des nouvelles thérapies